[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
francés 24 ya me acompaña en el estudio
marta moya marta bienvenida buena mañana
de juegos ya casi finalizamos esta
semana informativa abrimos entonces esta
revista de prensa tratando un tema que
ha generado muchas especulaciones mart
en los últimos meses y es la muerte de
más de diez oligarcas rusos desde que
inició la invasión en ucrania los casos
se han escenificado marta como suicidios
accidentes de carro también
envenenamiento con veneno de sapo y pues
muchas otras cosas más pero desde hace
meses también sobrevuela el fantasma de
si estos casos son verdaderamente
accidentales o tienen a ser así
asesinatos selectivos o marta como
analiza todo esto el medio español el
orden mundial buenos ya raúl pues el
orden mundial hace un análisis firmado
por víctor fidalgo que dice está el
kremlin asesinando a oligarca ruso y es
que como decía es más de 10 son 11
concretamente el último hace dos días
iban pecorino director gerente de la
empresa estatal de aviación que cayó por
un barco a alta velocidad
fue encontrado a cientos de kilómetros
dos días después este pues último
oligarca muerto se destaca porque
participó en el foro económico oriental
que se celebró en vladivostok a
principios de septiembre donde también
participó el presidente putin son como
decíamos pues oligarcas que han muerto
desde el inicio de la guerra en ucrania
y bueno pues destaca este análisis que
todos tienen un denominador común y es
que se dedicaban al sector del gas y del
petróleo
concretamente pues los que más han
muerto pertenecían a la empresa estatal
gazprom
decían que dice este análisis pues que
casi todos son víctimas de las sanciones
contra moscú pero pues que no se
manifestaron en contra de la guerra en
2000 en el año 2000 cuando putin llegó
al poder pues los oligarcas hacían y
deshacían a su antojo pero pues putin
los metió en vereda como dice este
análisis los llamó al orden y permitió
seguir con sus actividades pero pues sí
meterse en las actividades políticas en
el año 2000 pues el empresario más rico
de rusia mijaíl york jodorowsky financió
opositores quiso presentarse a
presidente y criticó a putin en
televisión por ello fue enviado a la
cárcel perdió perdió la compañía
petrolífera y tras años en prisión al
final se tuvo que exiliar en londres
ahora destaca collecting con un oligarca
que se ha manifestado contra la guerra y
que criticó a putin en instagram dice
que ha sido obligado a vender el 35 por
ciento de sus acciones a otro oligarca
afín a putin además dice pues que el
instituto varsovia sostiene que estos
oligarcas pueden ser o se pueden haber
muerto por tramas de corrupción o por en
conflictos internos y es que éstos
suelen ser violentos y no se transmiten
en televisión y puede que la guerra en
ucrania haya puesto el foco en ellos
bueno casualidades coincidencias pues
creo que son nunca seguimos el reino
unido porque los medios de carga en el
abb se reflejarán los últimos días y que
más de un centenar de personal de rey
carlos tercero recibir la notificación
de despido durante todas estas son re
fúnebres a su madre la reina isabel
segunda así es dice the gardian y la bbc
the gardian tuvo la exclusiva el
personal del rey carlos fue notificado
de despidos durante el servicio
religioso de isabel segunda en escocia y
es que los el personal declaró en house
la residencia oficial de carlos y camila
cuando éste era príncipe de gales pues
ciento un
personal que él tenía a tiempo completo
ahora podría ser despedido dice que los
más de 100 trabajadores están afectados
y furiosos ante esta notificación que
fue enviada pues durante los actos
fúnebres de la reina en escocia algunos
han trabajado durante años con el rey
carlos tercero y bueno pues esta medida
estos despidos podrían afectar a
secretarios privados oficina de finanzas
equipo de comunicaciones personal
doméstico que son quienes habrían
recibido
estas notificaciones además dice el
sindicato de servicios públicos y
comerciales está furioso ante esta
noticia y dice que es más o menos cruel
que se haya notificado durante el luto
nacional si bien esperaba han sido
textualmente cambios en las casas reales
la escala y la velocidad a la que esto
se ha anunciado es insensible en extremo
rápidamente ya para finalizar rosa hay
una celebración porque el medio y está
today celebra este 15 de septiembre una
fecha muy especial y marta perdóname
pues si este periódico estadounidense
celebra hoy 15 de septiembre 40 años en
su portada como para poder estar viendo
aquí a mis espaldas destacan algunos de
los acontecimientos que han cubierto
durante estas cuatro décadas como por
ejemplo pues la caída del muro de berlín
la muerte de michael jackson la primera
guerra del golfo ahora la pandemia de
coronavirus o la muerte de georg floyd
en su web también hacen un repaso de 40
hitos que han cubierto pues en estas
cuatro décadas destacando que son
importantes
y los editores para el público o para la
nación martha como siempre muchísimas
gracias por la revista de prensa del
dedo y mañana con más por supuesto
revista de prensa muchas gracias raúl
vamos ahora a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado del día